when I did the Nick Kroll Show we were  on that right I was on it  [ __ ] sat there one time and basically  knew the entire you knew you knew the  history of Hollywood the way I know like  70s NFL starting quarterbacks oh you  were going Studio heads producers  one I'm just gonna throw out the movie  you can tell me the Scandal behind it  okay the getaway uh my God this okay I  don't know if this is the right timing  but I'll guess Steve McQueen has started  [ __ ] Ali McGraw and uh and he's taken  her away from uh Robert Evans who's like  nose is collapsing at the age of 51 from  the amount of cocaine he's already done  and uh any and and and he gets away  Steve McQueen gets away